your driver thumbnail you press smells
like a like a butter trying to pop one
no a jar drops of popular raspberry tea
at the Peter
raspberry tea that's what's something
that's right usefulness really LGBTQ
content restricted mode what is
happening reject a nation it's greg alba
over here and it's john over here so
we're you just watch the baby driver
that movie was something special man no
a really special film john take it away
i realized while i was watching this
movie that i I seldom filled the the
joyousness of and the love for cinema
more than when I'm watching an Edgar
Wright joint it kind of just oozes off
the screen and then this one is is
pretty darn magical and it's a bit of a
it's a bit different from you know the
Cornetto trilogy if that's what you know
of his work yeah well fast cheeky it's
more just the pave film in its own genre
a little more straightforward yeah it's
a little less referential visually a
stuff it is rhythmic as ever yeah I mean
it has everything you'd want from a
tiger right film I have the awesome
editing the awesome pacing it has humor
in it it's got this vistas undeniable
rhythm and kinetic energy that you just
can't get from like other filmmakers
that work so flawlessly oftentimes I
think of other films that could be kind
of annoying or frustrating this because
this was only the first 20 30 minutes
moves in a really fast pace but then it
does take its time to slow it down just
a little bit enough to give it some
breathing room and I was glad the phone
does that because otherwise it would
have just been like a really fast music
video the entire time and instead of
turning into a Suicide Squad film it oh
yeah yeah the pace is even if even
though it's always got rhythm the pace
is tempered so it does pick up and slow
down appropriately for what kind of
story is happening because there's
there's more to the story than just a
crazy heist movie with awesome music
yeah well this is the story of baby
driver the character and so Al Gore is
the star the song he plays baby driver
and he is fantastic in this role before
we like really go into this movie review
I felt like even when I saw the trailers
and then watching this I do see like
drive similarities similar to the movie
Drive of the Ryan Gosling it's not like
the same kind of film at all but there
were there were things about it similar
types of things on paper in terms of the
script then I saw similar in terms of it
being a getaway driver a movie that's
really happened about its music and at
the same time his guy who falls in love
with a waitress and his whole motivation
is really behind his love for this one
woman hid their leaves but when you're
watching the movie it's not a parent
you're not going oh this is a lot like
trekkers it's such a tonal Esai listicle
II very different film and it doesn't
play out like drive and it's not like
drive created that storyline either yeah
like there is a certain classic element
and this one definitely adds a lot of
flourishes in touches of its own and it
calls back to a lot of different heist
movies and even though like Hays Code
era stuff the morality code era stuff
they kind of mixed those dynamics in in
a way that I thought was really charming
and even you can always tell how much
was in a file edgar wright is but
without it being distracting yeah it's a
cool crime world that you're actually
hopping into in this movie because and
it's wide variety of characters brings
all that to life started with angela
Elgort this man who you learn early on
has some type of condition where he has
to sort of drown out the noise by
playing music all the time it's more
than this but now look yes one is the
cool character motive where he has music
playing cuz it was just cool and the
character motive to begin with yeah yeah
but then it's like oh it's justified in
a really smart way right has a personal
thing also used to tinnitus is real and
annoying and I thought about this while
I was watching the movie and then we saw
that article and I have this thing after
the end of certain movies where they
have part like stories Edgar Wright was
talking about how the movies soundtrack
was really scored kind of by how the the
main character is choosing his music the
ralfie oh yeah you're hired movie he has
an iPod or iPods and he's choosing each
song based off whatever he's feeling
that moment it doesn't
just be a getaway driving experience it
could just be him walking away from
something meeting up with a girl oh yeah
you know with his foster father there's
music throughout this movement I thought
that was actually really clever you know
I mean you see it throughout the movie
but when he put it that way it clicked I
was like yeah he really is just kind of
deejaying this movie on yeah Green and I
feel like we do that in life that's what
makes a character so relatable
I don't know how passionate you are
whoever are watching this video right
now I know how passionate you are about
music but I certainly do that if I'm in
a good mood I want to place a good song
if I'm driving you've got a phone for
everything yeah I'm going to add news
sometimes you want to let's do a sad
song in order like a company or move
because sometimes music puts you in the
mood
and also the fantasy of being a getaway
driver you know like you're if you're
ever driving on the road and you're
driving fast as you want to put on a
song that really lifts your imagination
fly okay I like that the baby driver
character has such a specific tune for
any time he's doing his specifics how to
get away - he likes the time is arriving
to the song because he's playing he's
playing out his own fantasy in a way and
it's really cool because oh my god -
getaway driver I want to have a specific
tune as well to play along with all this
and I mean I do that like I'll restart
songs to time things or yeah I mean
lower stakes but you know like I used to
go out running and I always tailor my
run to the dynamics of the music like
especially if you're an audiophile I
think you'll definitely find something
spiritually relatable about this oh
absolutely
this is one of those movies I was
watching and every now and again you see
something where you're like this was
made for me now this I am exactly the
decision for well so yeah it's a love
letter for people who love music -
because it's a wide variety of songs
it's not just one specific type of genre
and it's not like listen cited
references movie again so it wasn't a
david 8 or spotify playlist yeah i mean
there it is a natural flow of yeah music
suicide it's got feel like people dumped
songs on top of it or we're like we put
another song here yeah and this movie
really does flow like a playlist yeah
because when I was watching the movie I
would be kind of surprised by how a lot
of times a scene would start to hear a
song it would fit perfectly and then
you'd see a baby driver start singing
along to the song in this like one
composed shot I guess it's surprising
because a lot of the times
don't get the rights to these songs
before filming the movie so we're real
you know what exactly you want to have
yeah it was cool to see how the songs
were very perfectly chosen in the
screenplay itself not just when they
were shooting on set but you could tell
that it was for the script and that's
not often a lot of times you might hear
writers writing with the song in mind
but they usually get those songs later
you could tell Edgar Wright probably had
to get a lot of these tracks before
filming even started oh yeah I mean
because the character even even beyond
just singing and you know drumming in
time on stuff the characters talked
about somethin sometimes we listen to
them together and comment oh yeah there
must have been a lot of clearances
beforehand Oh in a minute and I like the
touch of a move on from just the baby
driver character in a second I like the
touch of baby driver he's a rather
serious guy he's known to be kind of a
quiet guy but when he's singing along he
starts he gets goofy those are like
surprising touches they you don't really
you don't see in the trailer you don't
see in the marketing for this movie is
he starts to goof out when he's singing
along to the songs like a lot of us do
when we sing along to certain song like
like that yeah like you do when you
really love something and it's part of
ya day and you know it that's the day I
caught that with a couple characters
though like it seemed like you really
got to know these songs yeah I'm like
you know when when they start in those
moments singing along and kind of
dancing and stuff like it does feel real
well yeah it feels like a natural
relationship to the music and the
romance that start that blooms in this
movie with the character play by Lily
James Deborah Deborah I thought it was a
fantastic romantic aspect of this film
and I loved how their main bonding
moment is over the music you know I feel
like that happens often with me in life
with a girl it could be over music it
could be over movies when you share that
back and forth of the songs that you
both really love and you share that
together and that creates a sort of
instant connection yeah and I really
appreciated that aspect of it and she's
a great actress she did a fantastic job
in this role on a really bought their
chemistry everytime their first like
dialogue scene they had to get early
this smooth mofo man yeah maybe endeavor
their their chemistry throughout the
film is is awesome and there's a lot of
stuff that happens you know to that
relationship part of what I appreciate
it so much about this movie is that you
get all the cool heist intro stuff but
then it really takes its time to go boy
meets girl and we're gonna see that
through
for a while and the plot it's in the
credits the plot because the plot
unfolds very naturally and it goes in
and out of being a heist movie in a
really real way and that helps build the
stakes and establish my heart once the
classic it's the classic romantic B
story which is essentially the main
story eventually it's the part of the
movie and it's more than just some side
romantic stories become it's like the
central point for this character a baby
driver they were great but the whole
cast is fantastic the two other players
that really stood out to me where Jamie
Foxx and Jon Hamm oh yeah Jamie Foxx for
the character named bats that is fat
[ __ ] like yeah crazy
it doesn't overdo it he doesn't just
play crazy cuz he escalating Lee gets
like they reveal and more and more this
guy is a psychopath he is a sociopath he
is rather nuts yeah and I thought Jamie
Foxx was such a great he was so great at
provoking characters and bring and
bringing out darker sides in people and
also making nasty decisions he was so
good in his scenes I love this character
that's a real credit to the ensemble of
this movie because from from baby to
Buddy jon Hamm's is like throughout all
the characters they also lived in yeah
and everybody behaves very natural yeah
and that's the thing is like Jamie Foxx
gets on screening and you don't know
what's gonna happen with him after a
while this do going to be cool is you
get a things up probably both yeah and
the tension like that that's one thing
that really does have raised this from
Drive for me because like even if Drive
is an ensemble still like this is a lot
more of an ensemble baby is interesting
character because we we get his
character like his the quality of his
character throughout the movie the focal
point a part of the way that comes out
in the contrast with Jon Hamm
and with Jamie Foxx and where those
characters go and they don't go
necessarily in the places that you think
that you'd expect them to go I thought
they did that with a lot of characters
surprised that was the nice surprise of
it it was you know you get introduced a
lot of these characters you imagine a
certain scenarios will play out some
might play out in a way you might see
coming and some don't play out in the
way you would expect Jon Hamm you know
its introduces you know the likeable
high sky the guy who's like if everyone
doesn't a lot of people go through the
like baby driver
yeah everyone's kind of weirded out by
baby it seems like nobody knows what to
make of him yeah because he seems like
he's not fully invested in what's going
on he's a kid everyone that are like
much older than him he always has his
headphones on seems like he's not paying
attention to what's really going on Jon
Hamm and Isaac and solace they play this
couple who pull these heists together
and there's a ones who seem to just
really have a liking to baby driver they
seem to really like yeah I mean they're
they're having a good time yeah like
their the highs they're like the Bonnie
and Clyde oh yeah yeah yeah they're
they're charming and they're fun
together and you know as part of the
ensemble they don't really create a lot
of hot water for for baby leaves and it
seems like John Hamm would probably have
this like one specific note to play but
the film takes you by surprise yeah and
I don't know about giving any spoilers
you do get to see other layers and other
dimensions where he definitely becomes
one of the standout players of this
specific film and I really love what
they did that we don't see it coming you
don't know you look at the transition of
where he is coming and I feel like even
saying that you might not be able to see
what's coming yeah exactly so in and I
mean like that's the cleverness I like a
movie like this especially when it's a
crime or heist movies it really feels
like it's unfolding moment to moment
everything has its consequences and that
allows you to watch characters change
really naturally and I'm a fan of movies
that really delve into consequences
consequences emotional decisions being
made that cause everything to fall apart
average same with a heist movie of high
school wrong that's usually what the
plan doesn't go according to plan and
everyone's going to keep it together but
there's more than that happening in this
film than your typical heist film I
think ins ossified did a really good job
she's sexy she's wonderful I mean I love
her and from dusk till dawn as well he
or she is mainly here as the you know
like the wife to Jon Hamm she is the
support to jon Hamm's I didn't get as
much focus yeah even in her I mean I
thought she's still embodied the
character their chemistry is a lot more
than you really believe these two are
super into each other yeah I'm not happy
to see those those guys them both in you
know a movie like this and just be more
movie
yeah Jon Bernthal in the trailer - and
yes he's barely in the movie it's not a
fault with the movie whatsoever I just
felt as a Jon Bernthal fan yeah more
Jews when he's in the movie he's really
good dad I just love watching I love
watching Jon Bernthal and I thought like
oh hi so man he's really cool in the
film so far he's barely in the movie but
when he's there he's really great and
the only thing I wish is just as a fan
of Jon Bernthal was that he was in the
movie more yeah but it didn't for
Punisher yeah just be prepared but it
you know it's like the script or the
story doesn't necessarily call for his
character to be there for the whole film
I don't blame a tagger right for not
including that character more however
it's still a really nice touch to have
him in there for the time he was in the
film when those kinds of things are
always nice because they put you off
Center in terms of what you're expecting
can sometimes you know you have
recognizable actors and then you start
to expect how much you're going to see
them and where they're going to go and
what's going to happen to them without
giving too much away even in the little
details of how jumpered those characters
handled like it all fits in Natalie and
Kevin Spacey they got it the head honcho
the corrupt boss you know it was great
at those kind of roles and he is really
good in this movie did comic timing is
great the way he played the leadership
of the guy who pulls these heists
together it's fantastic I love his
relationship he has a baby driver or it
can be kind of manipulative and then
look at the kind of camera you just
manipulate I'm not sure where's really a
yes these weird nuances where you're
like at the right time he's almost kind
of charming and the rest of the time
he's sort of that dangerous deadpan yeah
like I want to piss this guy off but you
know he seems like a good humoured chap
I mean what I think might go on
recognized about his performance here is
there's more than just the money man and
more than built in mind guy because
there's these other characters who are
obviously more physically strong
probably more violent than Kevin Spacey
yet when he is talking to these people
where people are questioning him you man
you know he commends you know that no
one's going to like do anything to him
you know he's the dude in charge and the
other people will stand down him and I
love that touch that's not powerful of
an actor he is in this phone this movie
really is an insolvent put Ansel Elgort
really helling this film he's the heart
and soul but everybody shines slavery
every
even just down the cinematography in the
editing and the action the chase is
everything is punchy and everything
glistened and I guess one of the last
characters really touched on as a foster
father for baby driver played by CJ
Jones who is a he's deaf
yeah and that was a that was another
kind of nice heartwarming you really get
a sense for baby's life you know and
that just adds to that character you
know he lives with the deaf person so it
doesn't really matter because it all the
time he's kind of deaf too and no
relationship goes to waste here there's
no and that was a nice thing too I like
how that was something that you're not
really going to get interested as a deaf
guy and if they speak in sign language
as the film keeps going they do keep
coming back to it and they do keep
letting it evolve and I really
appreciated about the film because it so
has a lot more heart than you might I
mean it's Edgar Wright and it sums
always have a heart you know in
marketing you don't expect that cool
action yes way more than that well Edgar
right yeah he always manages by the end
of it even and you know the the Cornetto
trilogy flicks even in Scott Pilgrim
like he always manages to hit me in the
heartstrings and during this movie like
I was I was getting misty-eyed a couple
meds you know there's some really
poignant little moments in there
especially to with his mom you know with
Sky Ferreira who is an actual young
musician as well nothing is forgotten in
an Edgar Wright movie yeah like nothing
is there because it's cool the thing
that offers afterthought everything is
crafted in da house and with the car
chases that I thought were really neat
too it had that cool blend where I would
hear like what especially a filmmaker
community people will talk about two
different kinds of car chases you got
your fast and furious ones and then you
got your ones like in Jack Reacher where
it one shot you can really see what's
going on the camera lingers on here it's
a it's a blend of cool editing yet you
can really tell these are stunt drivers
some of it green screen most of the time
practical and I really appreciate about
that because there are certain shots
where you're like that's a real stunt
right that it's scary and dangerous and
you could tell as Al Gore probably had
to do some serious lessons to train for
this movie to be to get behind the wheel
oh yeah I think he said uh Ansel Elgort
John Hammond Jamie Foxx all did at least
some of their driving in this one yeah I
expect nothing less when watching the
film so I thought it was really well
edited I mean I think Edgar Wright songs
are always sharply edited finely tuned
because there's once the
about Egger right if you're a fan of
Edgar Wright you know he's all about the
details all about the little character
touches they will eventually come full
circle and everything every single thing
I had yeah this was the spy the best
summer movie I've seen oh yeah yeah it's
quick and punchy but it's not chaotic
enjoyable but it's also you know there
are stakes you know and a lot of times
in the action scenes when those hits
come they get you riled up watching this
and watching Planet of the Apes made me
think of you know because we've seen a
lot of blockbusters this summer a lot of
action a lot of people punching each
other and a lot of the time I go to
these movies and I'm not really feeling
the fight I'm just watching it because
it's cool and this is a movie where
there are times where you're like you're
afraid for baby and you you want those
punches or those crashes you know you
feel the catharsis with him and that's a
beautiful thing to be able to do with a
movie at all in a movie like this
especially I felt this was his most
different film Edgar Wright's done yes
it's funny but it's it's still really
grounded in a realm of reality to the
point where it doesn't
I wouldn't categorize it as a comedy
it's not they're all people people have
senses of humor yeah exactly because
this this was without a doubt as most
tension filled film he's ever done but
it never loses the fun yeah you know
yeah and when it does get tense and when
it does get you know a bit of harrowing
like it earned that you know there's a
couple of shot moments that happen where
you're like when the cool thing too is
with when it comes to the car chases
specifically or any of the chase there's
also a pretty spectacular foot chase in
this movie too I like that
you start out with the cool one you
introduce the movie on like here's how
cool it in control baby is and then the
rest of time like they did a great job
of making you really pay attention to
baby figuring it out because almost
nothing goes just according to plan
after that first chase you know like
everything is adjusting and things going
wrong and variables the thought that
goes into that like mad respect matters
fell you know because it feels natural
the second high sigil with sleek yeah
that whole car chase I was not expecting
any of how that happened brilliantly
done you account for like all these
heist movies are about like oh we got
this plan
but almost none of the plans go a
hundred percent to plan in this movie
and that's another thing I think is a
great touch a great new on even when
they do scrape it by and get out of
there it's not without some sloppy
moments or some some things that yeah
they weren't accounting because he's not
even perfect and I appreciate it yeah
totally because it wasn't like oh if
he's behind the wheel they're 100
percent okay yeah it's like you you know
he's the best but you know there's still
chance someone will get shot or killed
they're a good hands but there are also
people around their cars be folks with
guns you have one last element I'd like
to point out about this one that I
really enjoyed was the touch of how the
violence is effective in this film when
someone gets shot or killed because this
whole film is primarily from baby
drivers perspective I'd say like all
whole films actually from its
perspective is and whenever baby we are
with baby and your baby and whenever
he's witnessed to someone being killed
or someone being shot it affects him and
I like that but the violence never just
feels like oh all right it action till
you could see that it is a violent kind
of icky feeling towards while I get away
stuff all really cool when someone gets
shot or killed it's kind of upsetting
you know and it spends a lot of time
even during the heist moments
considering the collateral damage and
the people and coming face to face with
that and that's something that across
the board with these kinds of movies is
often missing in a meaningful way and
that sells everything beautifully
especially I ever do it's an r-rated
movie but I feel like pg-13 movies that
have a much higher body count than this
mist that all the time yeah I guess
that's part of why they get away with it
because we don't care so much because it
doesn't feel that real but this movie is
kind of all about what the consequences
are and now you see what he has to lose
and what his life is like why he might
not want to be this guy you know and
that's convincing it's not just you know
I want to get a crime yeah because it's
a fully lived in movie and I love that
about this I wrap this review up with my
consent to saying this is hands-down the
best summer movement of 2017 I feel like
we've seen all the big most likely to be
best one yeah and I feel like this is
probably I would say Adam all the ones
I've seen so far
best summer movie of 2017 yeah I'm with
you alright guys well did you see baby
driver do you like it like most people
know check it out if you haven't seen it
with only came out Wednesday like a
theatrical leaves Wednesday I know
people have seen it twice already yeah
Rosa Parra you've seen it twice on it I
would go again today yeah subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell John is dat John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and go check out
our exclusive perks and rewards video
content all over at our patreon thank
you guys for the month of June who have
participated in our patreon seriously
you guys are the best much love to
everyone over there and to everyone is
part of the reject nation in total
yeah man anybody is supporting the
rejects we appreciate you we love you
what